[Musique]
Janvier 1974, ils viennent d'emménager deux
mois avant un partenaire et j'étais le premier
sur la scène, il cherchait une lumière
quand quelque chose l'a heurté, c'est là que nous avons
trouvé la petite fille suspendue à ce
tuyau.
J'ai trouvé quelqu'un pour prendre le relais.  d être
très bon pour le BSU, il veut étendre
les unités et il a l'intention de faire en sorte que notre
approche soit pratique alors qui quelqu'un tu
veux plus que tout
Manson je vais t'obtenir un Manson c'est
100 000 $ et c'est tout à toi si tu
nous aides à identifier le  les personnes derrière les
photos de nos enfants et d'Emmitt ont
une autre fois porté disparu à Atlanta
en vous envoyant tous les deux vous vouloir là-bas pour la
durée
afin que tous ces enfants ne tuent pas, je
crois que c'est le cas
statistiquement rare pour les tueurs en série de
franchir les lignes raciales,
elle est aussi  statistiquement significatif
que le Klan tue les Noirs en devenant
incontrôlable,
il fait exploser cette arme va repenser son
investissement Je vous demande en tant que chef
de votre département qu'est-ce que Holden a dit
qui est si offensé  e ville nous devons
rester concentrés si vous êtes distrayant
J'ai des choses à gérer tout
cela est personnel elle avait les sous-vêtements de quelqu'un d'autre
ne faudra-t-il pas 30 savez-
vous où vos enfants c'est un
prédateur et si ce n'est
pas le cas  couple égoïste arrogant nous
ne pouvons pas avoir une vision tunnel et
quelles preuves y a-t-il pour soupçonner le
clan bientôt
nous avons 19 enfants noirs morts tu
me dis que c'est une coïncidence
une chose de plus que l'homme a envoyé un petit comme
vraiment petit essayez de ne pas  te regarder